hey
welcome to the party
how very nice of you to join us
this is really what we doing today
think
we need a new plan
you know what's cool
barbecue chefs
barbecue chefs are cool
what the hell is going on in here
what the
[ __ ]
what part of shut the [ __ ] up do you not
understand
hmm what the [ __ ] that
hey that doesn't suck
so you think you're bad don't you
no
no
i'm pretty sure you're doomed
cowboy up [ __ ]
hell yes
[ __ ] yeah
that's what i'm talking about jackpot
baby we have a winner
not just no
hell no
hell yeah
hell yes
oh my god why
you know what's cool
barbecue chefs
barbecue chefs cool
damn
that's gotta sting
what are you a [ __ ] mime
speak the [ __ ]
up i hope that subtitles somewhere cause
you're not making any sense
what this situation requires is a whole
lot more of you shutting your
[ __ ] ass up
oh ain't you cute
it's not that i think you're a stupid
[ __ ] it's just that when i'm
around you i feel like a [ __ ] genius
you cool you cool go get yourself a
[ __ ] cookie
what the [ __ ] are you looking at
you know what no just
no
no way
i hope you didn't think i was going to
say something nice
why is it that most nudists are people
you don't want to see naked
you know what's cool
barbecue chefs
barbecue chefs are cool
excuse me
unless a half-naked supermodel falls out
of the sky in the next three seconds i'm
outta here
oh oh oh oh oh
you're an idiot
you know what's cool
sushi
sushi school
i did not claw my way to the top of the
food chain to eat this [ __ ]
does it look even a little bit like i
give a [ __ ]
no
what's up guys prestige here hope you
enjoyed the little sam jackson video if
you did leave a like if you don't don't
and i'll know not to do it since it's a
little wary and definitely a very
different type of video than what i've
done before
a little update i will be continuing
here continuing
experience soon and also a new series
called minecraft's largest i got the
idea from another guy's channel link in
the description and i decided it wasn't
really a full set so i'd give it a shot
alright guys peace out